this is
uh kasaragi at all 2021
uh moonstruck sleep synchronization of
human sleep with the moon cycle under
field conditions so um
may i have my screen back thank you um
i'll just read a little bit from the
results consistent with previous studies
shorter sleep duration and delayed onset
onset of sleep were associated with
increased access to electric light
moreover both the duration and the time
of sleep onset showed a clear modulation
throughout the moon cycle that was
evident in the whole population
as well as in the individual communities
now this this
paper was was interesting and so anyway
which communities do they study
so they were i was just going to go back
and look they looked at indigenous
i'm going to mispronounce this i'm sure
toba slash
com qom uh communities in argentina
uh where they've got so these these
these peoples
um live all in in all range of
conditions from sort of their original
hunter-gatherer-like conditions to fully
urban
and so they went and looked at if memory
serves and i i did not have
enough time to look at either of these
sleep papers i want to talk about today
a little bit
um they looked at um
moon stage and um
sleep in the most like the original
indigenous hunting gathering or without
light pollution right very little
fully urbanized industrialized and then
a sort of an intermediate
stage that has some light pollution as
well and so they've effectively
controlled for a lot of stuff around
culture
right um because it's all the same it's
all the same lineage
and they still even the industrialized
people i think are still
honoring some of their established um
uh cultural norms um but
what they found was uh that uh
i mean exac exactly as you would expect
if you if you've ever been backpacking
or if you've ever thought about the fact
that we are evolved human beings on this
planet
um that we are cueing into the moon
and that when we have electric lights
that replace that effectively replace
the cues that we get from the moon
especially at night
we are less we are sleeping less we are
sleeping less well
um that absent electric lights this is
this is something
interesting i don't remember this is
from this article or if something that
they referenced in this article
that very rarely without electric lights
do people
people often go to bed after dark and
they may use fire they may use moonlight
they tend to go to bed later the more
full the moon is with a couple of
interesting exceptions like apparently i
think it was the hadza
who actually have explicit nighttime um
festivities on new moon nights
interestingly okay so you know they're
going to be exceptions but
um very rarely if ever
do people absent electric lights rise
before the sun rises
that going to bed after dark is common
but rising before the sun rises is not
and oh boy might not that have something
to do with how much more sleep-deprived
people feel
in the winter months and especially for
teenagers having to get up early when
it's still pitch
dark out rouse themselves from sleep
when we know that this is a time of life
when people need more sleep and
um and rousing them when it's still
dark out and sending a signal that
really until electric lights no human
beings were ever being sent
might be disruptive not just to sleep
that day but to sleep more broadly
and probably to the developing brain as
well okay so i still miss something
though okay so there's some sort of
synchrony with moon phase
which i would expect but what how does
it manifest what is it
when people go to bed is it how often
they wake up when they're sleeping what
kind of thing
um so there's less they sleep less
um when it's full oh so um
okay so there's there's two comparisons
that we're doing here and i was mostly
talking about the
the other one so the um sort of hunter
gatherer to
industrialize the more industrialized
you are the less in sync with the moon
phase you are
and the more destructive your sleep is
with regard to how does your sleep if
you are living without electric lights
how does your sleep change across the
moon cycle
people are trying to go to bed later uh
under full moon conditions
and under a full moon sleeping less per
night but that that is a
you know predictable fairly even
curve over time i've always wondered
about this because i have been kept up
by the moon
and it seems like we are very
we are well designed not to be kept up
by uh firelight um something we you and
i have talked about
uh a lot but um and you know for good
reason
you you would want it not to basically
be informing your pineal gland of what
time of
day it is because it doesn't contain
that information
right um but the fact that the moon
which is reflecting obviously some light
um somehow does keep you up if you're
sleeping in a circumstance where you
can't block out moonlight it's plenty to
keep you up
also interestingly many years ago when i
was doing
bat research in panama i was i can't
remember exactly what i was doing but i
spent
a night at the top of one of these
canopy towers i think i was
waiting for there were some uh fruits
maturing there and i was hoping to
see fruit bats which didn't work out but
nonetheless
um oh i we should come back to why i
might not have seen the fruit bats it
has to do with something called lunar
phobia
that exists in bats but in any case
i discovered that i could read under
moonlight it was just
barely the right amount of light to read
which is interesting you know any less
you know just slightly less than full
moon wouldn't be enough
um so i don't know if that's haphazard
or not but yeah
it's an interesting connection that is
an interesting connection
um and so just a another um another
paper that
came out recently that i had i was able
to spend even less time with so i'm just
really going to read a couple of
of sections from it is this um
forster at all and again you can show my
um my screen here zach um
we show that women's just the second
half of the abstract we show that
women's menstrual cycles with a period
longer than 27 days
were intimate intermittently synchronous
with the moon's luminance and our
gravimetric cycles
with age and upon exposure to artificial
nocturnal light
menstrual cycles shortened and lost the
synchrony we hypothesized that in
ancient times
human reproductive behavior was
synchronous with the moon but that our
modern lifestyles have changed
reproductive physiology and behavior
and i'm just going to read the very
beginning of the introduction too
in many marine species and some
terrestrial species reproductive
behavior is synchronized with a
particular phase of the lunar cycle
generally the full or the new moon
this arrangement increases reproductive
success by synchronizing the
reproductive behavior of the individual
members of a species
in light of this fact it is of interest
that the human menstrual cycle has
appeared close to that of the lunar
cycle and that several older studies
reported relation between the cycles
women whose cycles approach the 29 and a
half day period of the moon
have been reported to have the highest
likelihood to become pregnant
so that is you know that's the very
beginning of the article but i'd never
heard that before
but the closer the length of your cycle
is to that of the moon
the more fecund you appear to be super
interesting
but really you know not surprising at
all
that our sleep cycles for all human
beings
and that for uh reproductively
women of reproductive age uh menstrual
cycles
are attuned to the moon in some way is
should not be surprising and to that end
i got to these two articles by reading a
this week in science short article
um which um
here zach um
the final oh
didn't like it i didn't like it when i
made it bigger okay well
okay never mind um the final sentence is
both studies stop short of establishing
causality but suggest that even in
highly industrialized societies
celestial bodies affect our bodies on
earth
yeah i think uh yeah it's pretty it's
pretty interesting i do think the female
menstrual cycle and the
uh lunar phases are tightly connected
but
it does not require an actual effect of
the moon itself in other words there is
a mechanism for the moon
itself to to influence uh women this way
because they
you know under ancestral circumstances
would have you know
been monitoring effectively the the moon
phase but i don't think it's accidental
um that uh that close analogy
anyway maybe so so um yeah we should
definitely come back to this but you are
saying
um that this that the sleep work um
is of a different nature than the
menstrual cycle work
and that the menstrual cycle work may be
in fact
about a way that the human uh
body has figured out to basically keep
time yeah
keep time and awareness yeah that's keep
time keep a schedule keep an internal
schedule so that a woman
effectively you know in a species with
very few external indicators
of um of when we are at our most focused
um that if you can keep track of the
moon and
count to 29 then you can do a decent
job of of knowing when you're fertile
uh yes and also knowing when you are
pregnant
which may be the most important aspect
of this which is
um that in effect by if a woman's
period has accompanied a particular
phase of the moon
upon reaching that phase of the moon if
she is not near
her next period then she is at least
aware that there's something she has to
pay attention to which then
might have very deep implications for
her behavior because
raising a child alone is vastly dicier
than raising a child with a committed
[Music]
partner
you